panelists
and maybe we will have
an illuminating morning
you can begin christopher
thank you lewis well and thank you um
ladies and gentlemen for coming
um i'm acutely conscious of um
in the first place having already had my
say so to speak
at some length
and acutely conscious also of being the
only one who stands between you and um
people have greater expertise than
myself but i thought i would
offer you a play
on some recent words which you may have
been made to memorize um these words are
a peaceful um orderly democratic
transition
you may have heard these words recently
uttered in a self-conduct congratulatory
not to say self-regarding manner you may
have had the opportunity to tire of
hearing the words
peaceful orderly democratic transition
you may have wondered why
you are so often assured that the great
distinction of the united states is that
that is what it
does or has or can boast of
you may even think it's slightly
sinister that you keep on being told
that you have a peaceful democratic
orderly transition tradition you may
wonder even why if it was so obvious it
had to be restated
so often um so i'll stop saying it
myself hoping i've made my
play on words point and direct your
attention to um
two uh elements only of my uh folio on
on mr kissinger the first being the
election of 1968 in um
these united states
uh if i can make a claim to not to
originality perhaps but to a certain
synthesis in what i've written it would
be this i think i can say that harpers
has published for the first time the
the uh summer of all the available
evidence of how that election
was undermined distorted
fixed
by a
most appalling piece of cynicism by
richard nixon and others
in the course of which they went to
a foreign military dictatorship
negotiated secretly with that
dictatorship to undermine the
negotiating position of the american
government the united states government
and its legal
and visible negotiators in paris
made a made an illegal pact and an
amoral pact
that this foreign military dictatorship
would get a better deal from an incoming
republican administration and in making
this pact took out what one might
describe
euphemistically as a mortgage or lease
on another four years of an already
proven
uh immoral and atrocious war
um the combination of the subversion of
that election and the extension of that
war is the price of the bargain
qualified i think
be termed uh without any overstatement
the single wickedest act in the history
of this uh republic
and it may be doubted whether
it quite qualifies under the tradition
of a
democratic peaceful and orderly uh
transition
um
certainly of the um
of the four people who concerted that
policy
richard nixon attorney general john
mitchell vice president spyro agnew
and henry kissinger only one has escaped
any kind of indictment so far
uh john mitchell was the first attorney
general to go to jail
richard nixon had to accept a pardon in
order to avoid indictment and
impeachment and spyro agnew had to cop a
plea
also there's only one unindicted
co-conspirator
still on the loose i suggest that's a
reproach to a country that considers
itself to be bound by law
and um bound by justice
um
democratic peaceful orderly transition
was also the great boast
and rightly so
of the people of chile our southern
neighbor
a country that has never
offended or threatened to offend
or had the capacity to offend or
threaten the united states
it was distinguished among its
hemispheric neighbors precisely by the
fact that
when its people had voted their choice
formed the next government and the armed
forces or the police or the oligarchy
didn't determine that and couldn't
intervene in it
and that wouldn't remain the state of
affairs until 1970 when it was coldly
decided
at a meeting in washington held among
others by dr kissinger there was to be
no peaceful democratic orderly
transition in chile
that the uh 60-day constitutionally
mandated waiting period between the
election of a president in this case
salvador allende
and his confirmation inauguration
would be used
for a campaign of murder
and subversion in order that that
transition not occur
and this involved the cold-blooded
planning of of the murder of general
renee schneider
the head of the chilean armed forces
an honorable conservative and
constitutionalist officer in a country
which i repeat was a democracy
that had
opened diplomatic relations and trade
relations with the united states and
posed no threat to it
and that murder is now
what a lawyer i think could decently
call a lay down case
a lay down case from soup to nuts we
know
who commissioned it who paid for it who
organized it who shipped the illegal
money who shipped the dirty weapons
to chile to have this done
and who paid the murderers after the
crime had been committed and the same
name and the same face
recurs throughout we charge henrique
with murder for that and we say that a
society that
tolerates him is tolerating that too and
that's therefore a big reproach
to a society that claims to be bound by
law
responsive to justice
and it's a it's of course an utter
cynical
negation of all the claims that have
been made about
democratic peaceful orderly transition
um as i said of the um of the four
people who
conducted the election subversion in
1968 only one remains unindicted
if you now look at the international
scene and see the people with whom dr
kissinger was in business
during his tenure in office you will
find that almost all of them also are in
jail in their own countries or are going
there
of of mr kessinger's business and
political partners mr suharto
general pinochet uh general papadopoulos
in uh in greece
uh the the uh brigadiers in bangladesh
who um
committed the assassination of sheikh
mujib
and quite a number of others
are in jail i'm glad to say tried in
courts
proper courts in their own countries
and condemned to life imprisonment
once again the grand exception is the
man who made their political careers or
military careers
possible and he dwells as a
an honored citizen among us and we say
too that that is our approach
your approach to any society that
considers itself internationally law
bound
or
responsive to the claims of justice on
the
international scale so
um let that be my
opening
bid and let me accept
counteroffers from or enlargements or um
a very strong bid undercuts from
christopher
uh these distinguished gentlemen thank
you scott
uh christopher i'm not sure this is
directly responsive to your bid but i
think
i share
with you and everyone here a deep
concern about accountability